Speaker 1: Well, in the United States, it
was Mother's Day yesterday, and the failed
former and wannabe future president Donald
Trump issued a mother's Day greeting, I guess,
with peace, love and attacks on women married
to Marxists or something like that, then degenerating
into an even more unhinged attack on Kaitlan
Collins and other people.
Let's take a very quick look at it.
This was all on Trump's platform.
Truth, social censure, Trump not reactivating
in any serious way on Twitter, but regularly
posting to truth, starting with, quote, Happy
Mother's Day to all in particular, the mothers,
wives and lovers of the radical left fascists,
Marxists and communists who are doing everything
within their power to destroy and obliterate
our once great capitalist country.
Please make these complete capital L lunatics
and capital M maniacs.
Capital K Kinder Capital G. Gentler.
Capital S softer.
And most importantly, yes, Capital S smarter
so that we can quickly make America great
again.
This is a really, really sick Mother's Day
message and a bizarre one.
He then turned his ire from the lovers, lovers
of Marxists to Ron DeSantis posting, quote,
Rob de sanctimonious.
And his poll numbers are dropping like a rock.
I would almost be inclined to say these are
record falls.
The question is, Rob, just young, inexperienced
or naive?
Or more troubling, is he a fool who has no
idea what he is doing?
We already have one of those in office.
We don't need another one MAGA.
So an attack on Rob de Sanctimonious then
going after Kaitlan Collins, who was the host
of the Trump CNN town hall that went so horribly
wrong last week, posting quote, It's really
amazing to watch the head of CNN get absolutely
lambasted for asking me to do a so-called
town hall.
In all fairness, nobody had any problems with
what he wanted to do until after the show
started.
That's a lie.
Many people had a problem with it when they
quickly realized that Miss Collins was not
exactly Barbara Walters or even close.
That's when the trouble from the radical left
started.
Neurotic little AOC with the bad looking boyfriend
went crazy.
He owns CNN.
He's in their head.
They screamed CNN.
Take the great ratings.
You know, I have to say what this is.
This is whacked, completely whacked out of
his gourd.
But one thing that does seem to be true.
Is that the Trump CNN town hall.
Reminded others like Fox News.
Maybe there is a few ratings points to be
had with very little effort in doing Trump
stuff.
And so until the Iowa rally was canceled over
the weekend, Trump's Iowa rally was canceled.
Fox News planned to air it, even though for
a while now they have not aired Trump's rallies,
which is interesting and clearly a reaction
to what they saw work relatively well for
CNN.
Now, one last note on this.
To be thorough, the actual live ratings for
the Trump CNN town hall weren't that good.
They were like in the 3 million range.
The issue is it generated so much discussion
and the clips were shared and it was discussed
for days that CNN got a lot of mileage out
of it.
But the the live event itself didn't actually
do that well from a ratings perspective.
Okay.
And then lastly, as part of this deranged
rant from Trump untruth, quote, Unless the
Republicans get everything they are asking
for in terms of cost cutting, in particular
all of the trillions of dollars of inflation
causing waste that has stupidly been approved
over the last two years, much of it for the
Green New Deal con job.
They will have no choice but to let the Biden
administration default on U.S. debt better
now than later, especially with $32 trillion
of debt out there.
When I was president, the Dems would cavalierly
say they don't care about default.
So, so many lies here.
So many lies.
First of all, the deficit has actually grown.
I'm sorry.
The debt has grown more slowly under Biden
than under Trump.
So the idea of Biden is this out-of-control
spending guy.
That's a lie.
Secondly, the Green New Deal is not law.
And continuing to talk about all of the spending
on Green New Deal.
The Green New Deal is not law.
The Inflation Reduction Act does contain certain
things like we're going to build electric
vehicle chargers and things like that.
But there is no Green New Deal in the law
right now.
And lastly, the idea of Trump saying let the
U.S. default on its debt.
It's ridiculous.
It's not going to happen.
And they love to pretend like it actually
might.
But I don't think even Trump understands what
would happen if that were the case.
So a beautiful Mother's Day on troth Essential
for failed former President Donald Trump.
White supremacists marched in Washington,
DC wearing masks, by the way.
I guess they're not that confident in the
world knowing who they are and what they believe.
There's a Newsweek report hundreds of white
supremacists march on Capitol with shields
and battle drums.
We'll look at a video in a moment.
Video posted to social media showed hundreds
of members of the white supremacist group
Patriot Front marched to the United States
Capitol carrying shields and battle drums
On Saturday.
By the way, I hear sometimes supremacist pronounced
supremacist like I think Lindsey Graham says
it that way.
And some others, I don't know where they're
getting supremacist.
Supremacist is the word.
At least 150 members of the far right group
wearing masks to conceal their identity were
seen marching along the National Mall and
in downtown DC, videos posted to Twitter showed
them carrying American flags and holding signs
that read Reclaim America.
The march comes as experts warn about the
rise of white supremacist groups and sentiment
in the U.S.
According to a study from the Anti-Defamation
League from March, a 38% increase in white
supremacist activity was seen from 2021 to
2022, with more than 67 incidents reported
throughout the year.
In the videos, police officers are seen escorting
Patriot front members to separate them from
counter-protesters.
So we have a video here.
I will describe it for the people that are
only listening today, you do indeed see a
police sort of escort, I think, on bikes around
the Patriot front, guys.
They all seem to be wearing.
I guess the uniform they've chosen is tight
khaki pants, although I don't know that they're
supposed to be tight.
Some of them may just have pants that are
too small, tight khaki pants and then blue
shirts, masks and hats.
They are marching.
They are carrying shields.
Let's listen right now as we continue to watch
this and you see the police escort closing
around them.
What is the deal with the shields?
I don't know.
Speaker 3: Well.
Speaker 1: And off they go.
Why do they hide their identities?
Clearly, they realize there might be real
world consequences to.
Being identified as a white supremacists?
I don't know.
All right.
So if you look online, there's a bunch of
magazines convinced that this is a false flag
event.
Now, what they mean by that, I don't really
know.
I guess what they're saying is it's a false
flag and that these aren't really white supremacists.
This is actually Antifa or, I don't know,
BLM or Hunter Biden's extended family.
I don't know.
It's people pretending to be white supremacists.
And white supremacists don't really exist.
Maybe.
I don't really know.
But you would then ask yourself if it's a
false flag, they should have no problem denouncing
what they stand for, even if they're pretending
to stand for that.
But they don't do that either.
It's all very weird.
But white supremacists marching in D.C. with
tight pants, boots, masks, flags, some of
the flags upside down, and a extremely, extremely
solid police escort, I must say.